INTRO:
Being a politician is extremely difficult.
Regardless of how fair, transparent, honest,
and well-spoken you are, roughly half the
population will always despise you simply
because both of you have fundamentally different
beliefs.
Considering this, if you’re a politician,
you wanna make sure that you don’t wanna
piss off the side that supports you because
then you’re really screwed.
As you can see from the clip though, that’s
exactly what UK’s prime minister Boris Johnson
has done.
Over the past couple of months, Johnson has
been flamed by basically everyone in parliament
including most of the members in his own party.
In fact, 27 out of the 31 Scottish Conservative
MSPs, or basically representatives, have publicly
voiced their disapproval of Johnson.
Likewise, Johnson’s public approval ratings
have never been more atrocious.
At the peak of his unpopularity, 73% of adults
felt that Johnson was performing poorly.
Considering this overwhelming negative feedback,
many members of Johnson’s inner circle have
already resigned like Allegra Stratton.
Johnson, however, has bit his tongue and tried
his best to at least finish out his term.
So, here’s what happened to Boris Johnson
and why the UK is demanding that he resign
as prime minister.
1ST LOCKDOWN:
Taking a look back, the root of Johnson’s
unpopularity can be traced back to March 23,
2020.
On this fateful day, the UK government issued
a strict stay-at-home lockdown across the
country.
Restaurants, pubs, and non-essential retailers
were all told to close, and citizens were
restricted to traveling only to and from essential
work.
But despite these strict orders for citizens
and businesses, it seems like Johnson and
his staffers felt that these rules did not
apply to them.
In fact, many pictures and videos that would
eventually be leaked suggest that his inner
circle had little regard for these restrictions.
The first example of this was a get-together
that took place on May 15, 2020.
At the time, the official restrictions stated
that people had to maintain 2 meters worth
of social distancing and only a maximum of
2 people from different households were allowed
to meet in a public place.
Judging from the picture though, about a dozen
people were meeting in the garden, no one
was wearing masks, and social distancing is
basically nonexistent.
Johnson has insisted that this was simply
a business meeting, but the inclusion of his
wife in the meeting suggests otherwise.
Moving forward 5 days, on May 20, 2020, Johnson’s
senior aide Martin Reynold’s invited roughly
30-40 staff members to a garden picnic.
Two of these invitees were of course Johnson
and his wife Carrie who both attended.
Reports suggest many of Johnson’s staff
members even advised him that this get-together
was in violation of lockdown restrictions.
Yet, Johnson attended anyway and he has denied
receiving warnings about the party’s violations.
Moving forward another month, we have Johnson’s
56th birthday which took palace on June 19,
2020.
By this point, covid restrictions had been
lightened up a decent amount, and gatherings
up to 6 people were allowed outdoors.
But for Johnson’s birthday, not only did
30 people gather which is 5 times the permitted
amount, but they would gather indoors.
Fortunately, UK’s covid restrictions would
lighten up even more starting on July 17,
2020, so it seemed like these parties were
something that Johnson could leave behind
in the rearview mirror.
In reality, though, the pandemic had just
begun.
2ND LOCKDOWN:
As you guys now know, Covid cases would pick
up once again in late 2020 as the world faced
a second wave.
As a result, on October 31, 2020, Johnson
would announce a second round of strict lockdowns.
Just like the first round, restaurants, pubs,
gyms, and nonessential retailers all had to
shut down for at least 4 weeks.
Johnson went on to apologize that Christmas
may be very different that year and that he
hopes that taking early action can prevent
even more action from being required.
Despite this somber speech, just 2 weeks later
on November 13, 2020, staff members would
reportedly attend a gathering with Carrie
Johnson at the prime minister’s residence.
Similarly, just two weeks after this on November
27, 2020, a party would be thrown for Johnson’s
senior aide Cleo Watson, and Johnson would
even give a speech at this event.
A few weeks later on December 14, 2020, Johnson’s
Conservative party would host a full-on party
at their HQ in Westminster.
I think you get the gist of what’s going
on.
While the nation was under strict lockdown,
Johnson and colleagues basically just continued
on with daily life.
On December 17, 2020, a leaving party was
thrown at the Cabinet office.
Similarly January 14, 2021, another gathering
was hosted to celebrate the departure of two
private secretaries.
By this point, it was clear that Johnson didn’t
accidentally make a violation here or there.
His colleagues and he were consistently violating
Covid restrictions week after week, but the
nail in the coffin didn’t come till April
16, 2021.
This time, the Downing Street staff hosted
not one but two parties.
Fortunately, Johnson did not attend either
of these and Covid restrictions were much
looser by this point and vaccines were pretty
readily available.
But what made these parties fateful was their
ill timing.
You see, just one week before these parties,
Queen Elizabeth II’s husband Prince Philip,
Duke of Edinburgh passed away on April 9,
2021.
The funeral was planned for April 17, 2020,
which meant that the Downing street parties
took place the night before the funeral.
For obvious reasons, much of the UK felt that
these parties were extremely distasteful and
disrespectful.
This led to the press looking into the prime
minister’s history with parties, and their
findings would annihilate Johnson’s reputation.
EXPOSED:
Over the next several months, the media along
with investigators would uncover more and
more of the parties and gatherings we just
discussed, and the public would grow more
and more irritated with each discovery.
But, the piece of evidence that sent the public
over the edge was a leaked video of Johnson’s
press secretary, Allegra Stratton, and a bunch
of her colleagues joking about a Christmas
business meeting and not following social
distancing.
Shortly after this video was leaked, Allegra
would announce her resignation in tears.
Many people in the comments have gone on to
claim that the tears are fake and that this
is terrible acting.
But personally, I think the tears are in fact
genuine.
However, like other comments have pointed
out, the tears are likely not because she’s
sorry for her mistake, but because she got
caught and is about to lose her job.
After this video was leaked, Johnson had no
choice but to conduct an official investigation
into the matter.
Johnson would task Cabinet Secretary Simon
Case with conducting the investigation, but
he would soon be replaced by civil servant
Sue Gray as it was uncovered that one of the
parties took place at Simon’s own office.
Over the next month and a half, Sue would
conduct her investigation which uncovered
loads of quote “extremely damning” evidence.
Sue apparently found dozens of photos showing
Johnson attending events with extremely loose
or no covid restrictions.
But unfortunately, much of this evidence has
yet to be released, and it’s unclear if
it’ll ever be released.
You see, Sue was supposed to publish her full
25-page report on the last week of January.
But, on January 28, it was revealed that Sue’s
report would only be 11 pages long and that
key details would be left out in order to
quote on quote avoid any prejudice to their
investigation.
On top of this, Johnson got to review the
contents of the report for 3 days before it
was finally published on January 31, 2022.
Unfortunately for Johnson, some of the worst
public and political backlash we’ve seen
in modern history would follow soon after.
BACKLASH:
On the surface, it seems like people are pissed
that Johnson didn’t take Covid that seriously
when it comes to his personal actions.
But, I think people’s distaste for Johnson
is much more deeprooted them him simply not
taking Covid seriously.
A bunch of world leaders didn’t take the
pandemic that seriously, but they’re not
receiving the same backlash that Johnson is,
and I think the key reason for this is that
they were consistent, unlike Johnson.
Take Trump for example.
He didn’t take the pandemic too seriously
either.
He often held massive gatherings at the White
House and he even held a rally with thousands
of people in June of 2020.
While Trump did receive a lot of from the
media and democrats, republicans didn’t
exactly turn on him because he was consistent
with his messaging.
Trump’s entire premise was that the illness
was here to stay and that everyone should
return to normal life including returning
to work and school.
Whether you agree with this perspective or
not is besides the point.
The point is that Trump practiced what he
preached.
Johnson, however, did not.
To please the media and a part of the public,
Johnson implemented severe covid restrictions,
but in his personal life, he didn’t follow
any of these.
This left quite a sour taste in many British
people’s mouths as it felt like Johnson
and his colleagues thought that they were
above the law.
While everyday citizens were limited from
going to work, attending school, and opening
up their local businesses, Johnson was behaving
like nothing was happening.
What’s even more surprising though than
the public being upset is that politicians
are also upset.
All the comments on the initial video I showed
you guys are gushing over how crazy it is
to finally see a politician being held accountable.
And while I agree that it’s nice that Johnson’s
peers are calling him out on his actions,
I also think that many of them likely have
ulterior motives.
Here’s the thing, prime ministers aren’t
directly voted for in the UK.
Rather, British citizens vote for members
of parliament, and the leader of the majority
party becomes the prime minister.
As a result, it’s the local elections that
determine the national leader.
This might be a bit confusing because it’s
basically the opposite in the US.
Americans mainly just vote for a president
and all of their local election choices are
just the candidates from the same party.
As a result, it’s in American politicians’
best interest to align with the winning candidate.
In the UK though, given that citizens don’t
vote for the prime minister directly, local
candidates don’t really care about aligning
with the prime minister.
In fact, it would probably be beneficial for
them if Boris Johnson is ousted because it
gives them a chance to move up.
With that being said, Johnson’s colleagues
turning on him may have more to do with politics
than serving justice.
But hey, at least he’s being held accountable.
END OF POLITICAL CAREER?:
At the end of the day, Johnson’s seemingly
elitist view along with his colleagues’
lack of dependence on him have really torn
apart Johnson’s reputation.
But, Johnson has had one saving grace which
is Russia’s invasion of Ukraine.
Russia’s invasion has turned international
attention away from Johnson and onto Putin,
Zelenskyy, Russia, Ukraine, NATO, and so on
and so forth.
In other words, the severity of Putin’s
actions has made most people forget about
Johnson’s actions.
Aside from diverting attention, Russia’s
invasion has given Johnson the perfect opportunity
to redeem himself by supporting Ukraine, letting
in refugees, and acting as a western hero
in the war.
All of his efforts seem to paying off as the
distaste for Johnson has noticeably declined
over the past 2 months from 73% down to 63%.
Johnson still has a lot of work to do to win
back support from his colleagues and the public.
But given that UK’s next general election
is taking place till May 2, 2024, Johnson
has plenty of time to do damage control.
Also, in terms of resignation, given that
Johnson hasn’t already resigned, it’s
extremely unlikely that Johnson will resign
due to PartyGate, and Johnson will likely
just finish out his term.
But that’s just what I think.
Do you guys think Johnson should be fired?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think all politicians
need to be held more accountable.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.